and thank you robert for introducing
yourself
it's pretty interesting uh the pain in
which you're graduating in right now
thank you and
others also can take this time to
introduce themselves in the chat and let
us know
about their educational background their
research and trust and what makes them
join the webinar today
starting in more seven minutes from now
thank you for joining
a very warm good morning good afternoon
or good evening in whichever part of the
world you are i would like to welcome
you all for today's webinar on chem
informatics for biomedical drug
discovery this program is designed to
address the challenges associated with
understanding modeling screening and
applying chem informatics strategies to
improve drug discovery results
the process of finding a new drug
against a chosen target for a particular
disease usually involves high throughput
screening wherein large libraries of
chemicals are tested for their ability
to modify the target with contributions
from leading researchers in academia and
by technology pharmaceutical industry as
well as experts from the software
industry this comprehensive mental
guided training program explains how
kevin informatics enhances drug
discipline
so before we begin with today's webinar
uh i would like to introduce us
we are a us-based bioinformatics company
who is working with multiple academic
and commercial collaborators to develop
easy-to-use inaudible tools and our
mission is to make bioinformatics more
accessible
the omix project training has been
completed by over 24 000 participants
from 187 countries in over 300 workshops
and due to this fast growth our team is
working with local and regional
coordinators that are helping refine the
local program logistics and leverage our
online training resources adapting them
to the needs of students and researchers
around the world
the training has been completed by
participants in six different
specialization tracks which includes
oncology infectious diseases precision
medicine neuroscience data science or
biomedical data and comprehensive
training on comics data analysis
over the past several years we have had
the privilege with a number of
organizations developing a training
program for research on indian students
faculty and advertising bioinformatics
making this discipline as a symbol to
thousands of students and football team
around the world
the omixlogic research-based training
programs are a result of close
collaboration between buying biotech and
numerous academic institutions that have
participated in content evaluation
curriculum review and project design
in this program we will combine
pre-recorded mentor sessions online live
q and a sessions self-fire study
materials which include courses on the
omixlogic learn portal an example
projects as well i will be shortly
taking you through the portal and uh
show the resources to all of you that
you would never reach
which also includes practical
assignments and quizzes for an immersive
experience that has to be that has
proven to be effective in our well-known
and respected omics logic programs
the program includes pre-recorded mentor
sessions on the program topics by dr
paneeth
a drug discovery scientist and
industrial analytics manager at
accenture he holds a phd in drug
discovery and is a strong advocator for
using advanced technology in
pharmaceutical research and
development as a part of the program
once you have completed the associated
resources and done with watching the
pre-recorded session video of the
program page you can then schedule a
meeting with the mentors and clarify
your questions we will also add you to
our bioinformatics community group on
our site where you can interact with the
mentor and put your questions in the
group for the mentors to answer
and once you are specialized in the
field of chemical informatics you can
further work on a research project under
the mental guidance of dr ajit and dr
udain from faban who are industry
specialists with an expertise in the
field so the process begins with the
research proposal and then you discuss
your proposal with the mentor to make
any changes if required and proceed
ahead with your research project and
meet the mentor in these research
fellowship meetings twice every week to
get your project completed and finally
published on omixologic learn portal and
repetitive journals
the program will leverage our top rated
online tutorials using the omnislogic
learn portal with smart tracking of
activity and curated data sets which are
designed for a great learning experience
so let's quickly sign up on the portal
just to make sure that those who have
joined us for the first time you have an
account already already on the portal
and have access to the resources i'll
quickly give a demo on how you can have
your account ready on the on project
launch portal and if you have any
questions or face any technical issues
our team is here to assist you so do let
us
i'll just now quickly visit the
omnislogic learn portal
i'll put the link to the portal in the
chat box
for
those
who are new
to have their accounts up ready
if you already have an account please
let me know in the chat by putting in a
one or yes maybe and if you are signing
up right now with me then please follow
these steps you need to click on the
login button to create an account for
yourself
i think you can put in the credentials
as required here or use any one of your
social media accounts to do so i will
just quickly pick one of my google
accounts to sign in to my account on the
portal
you can take this time to
sign in your for your account as well
awaiting responses in the chat box uh
for those who already have an account
please put awareness yes maybe and those
who are creating their accounts please
put a one once done
so we know that we are
going to begin with today's session
i'll
pause for a minute or two here for you
to have an account ready so that you can
follow along the resources and also
go through these lessons and courses
from the mentors taking you through them
and for those who have already created
an account the next step for them is to
complete their profile please make sure
that you have an updated profile on the
omnislogic loan program which includes a
profile picture your name should be in
title case uh to make sure that this is
the same format that reflects on the
certificate please make sure that your
name is in the title case please connect
your social media accounts and add a
brief file about yourself that would
include your educational background and
your research and trust as well
this is a section which will help you
monitor your progress and also ask the
mentors we can see your activity log
here and see what you have been
completing as a part of the program and
once you complete a specific coursework
as a part of the program you will be
able to follow your progress and also
download a certificate from the courses
tab here on the portal and also you can
access a certificate from the
certificates tab
that was about the profile section and
why is it important to have a complete
profile
now i'll quickly help you understand how
you can navigate easily on the
ormislogic non-portal so once you have
your account ready up here and have
completed your profile you will have the
access to the courses as a part of the
chem informatics program now when you
click on the courses tab in the menu bar
you will find a list of tags here on the
right side that you can
click on to access the resources for the
particular program and we will be
following the program page
for uh the session uh show you the
recordings and also the resources that
you are required to go through as a part
of this program so towards the end of
the session i will be taking you shortly
through the session schedule of the
program and we discuss what all we will
be covering from the uh the sessions in
the program so this is the program page
that we've been answering to but before
we do that let us start with we begin
with today's session
i would now like to pass on the stage to
doctor moment and i will take up the
message in the chat in the chat section
itself thank you over to you sir
thank you sunalika for the introduction
and for letting everyone uh log into the
resources
and we will be sharing uh some of those
resources
during the presentation and uh i hope
that uh
we can together for uh do this some of
the hands-on part that we have planned
for the
uh for today's webinar so i'll start
with uh by sharing my screen
so
snydika can you let me
yes somebody can see your screen
all right um
thank you again
for all of you who have joined today's
session and wanted to learn about
uh chem informatics in biomedical drug
discovery so for today's session we did
we discussed and we thought that we will
be it will be nice
to discuss some of the critical
opportunities and challenges that are
being faced by the industry faced by
research labs and uh we wanted to
discuss uh about the overview of how
this entire modern drug discovery
pipeline is now functioning
and it's producing results in many
places and many of you are excited for
the same reasons to be able to
explore more of this and to be able to
learn and apply to some of your own
research
so um as we go on for the session as we
discuss different uh different
different agendas for today's meeting
i'd like to request an alika to maybe
prepare a project proposal form
and uh share it with me uh sonalika if
you can do that uh so towards the end of
this session i won't want to discuss the
project proposal and how one can start
working on a research idea already uh
starting with the uh
as the program starts
in uh weeks time so uh
uh as uh we've been discussing that
there are certain agendas that we would
want to cover one of those agendas is
precision medicine so when we are
discussing about biomedical drug
discovery when we are discussing about
the use of chem informatics in
biomedical drug discovery we are talking
about a specific specialization that
involves structural biology that
involves understanding of how uh to
analyze three-dimensional structures in
three-dimensional space and how to uh
you know devise strategies as well so uh
i mean to think about that there are
other two other two aspects that we
would be discussing those are drug
designing and drug repurposing
which are
used quite often in even in industry as
well as in academia
and during the presentation and during
the session uh i'll be happy to answer
questions so please put there put your
questions in the chat
so in this training program
uh
what we have discussed what we have
discussed so far is about the
different aspects of
biomedical drug discovery but in the
training program we are going to follow
a curriculum and that curriculum would
include a specific softwares and tools
which are open source and we'll be able
to share with you how to install those
softwares and how to use them on the
cloud and what are the
uh what are the associated resources
that you can utilize to make the most
out of this uh training program that is
upcoming so we have planned uh a very
detailed curriculum that i'll be
showcasing and i'll be going through
but before that i wanted to start with
the fact that what we are doing and why
we are doing this and why we should uh
learn about all of this
so let's start with the fact that
how the modern biomedical drug discovery
pipeline
works and what are the different
components and how can this be an entire
story like a complete story with all the
where we know all the pieces
because what is ha what has happened and
what we know for sure is that
for many drugs that we've been using so
frequently
we don't know the mechanism of action so
having a complete knowledge of mechanism
of action
is is something that the modern
biomedical drug discovery is utilizing
uh
by that is being utilized by former
computational biology or bioinformatics
company that are providing services
as well as
uh
research labs and researchers so how do
we incorporate that
all sort of information into the model
so that it makes sense so that it
relates really close to what is
happening biologically or what is
happening in real life situation so uh i
mean in modern biomedical drug discovery
pipeline uh there are certain aspects
that we
that we have covered uh in our omics
logic portal and to those participants
who will be joining this program
obviously connecting those dots and then
uh figuring out a
maybe targeted protein or a proposal
would make total sense so um
as we were discussing precision medicine
so precision medicine initiate
initiating from
clinical and molecular pharmacology
introduces a new era in healthcare right
that the the entire purpose of this is
that it aims to identify and predict the
optimum treatment for a patient or a
cohort
now
uh evidence-based medicine uh integrates
information from basic in vivo
observational studies and then clinical
trials uh where we're done to do
meta-analysis data for clinical
considerations so hence it it can be
stated that this uh this entire like
often we see that population averages uh
but
population averages the forest
but misses the tree so the trees are
here individual patients right where the
utilization of precision medicine may
not see the uh may not see the forest
but for the trees and that is quite uh
relevant and important that we have
realized that uh all of us are uh having
a different genetic makeup uh
which makes us different from each other
we react to different medicines
differently so all that information uh
can be you know modeled together so that
we can
reach to a place where we can give
recommendations based on the
personalized way of
uh
reporting so now the state of our tools
for modeling and simulations and
pharmacology they try to extrapolate
knowledge gain gain through this
experimental process or procedures with
either either a top top-down approach or
a bottom-up bottom-up approach so this
modeling and simulation often it what it
does is that it tries to connect the
dots and reveals the bigger picture so
picture the bigger picture is the
population or the forest so considering
what kind of individuals or trees are in
there we have to understand and we have
to figure out at an atomic level and
which is very fascinating and really uh
really uh nice to know that from uh
sequence level we are looking at the
functional level and then we are looking
at the
mechanistic level uh by looking at the
chemistry that is going on
in the within the molecules so uh in
this program there are some components
that is really exciting for me and i
guess it would be exciting for all of
you as well so um we would want to
discuss this that how research allows
us to utilize experimental or clinical
data through this molecule
modeling and simulation simulation of
biomedical tools and this will help and
this is helping for sure in disease
progression dynamics in machine machine
learning and relevant bioengineering
approaches for either drug response
prediction where like including drug
interactions
drug interaction data is also included
then adverse drug reactions data is also
included and that all of this is leading
to drug repurposing or you know drug
discovery
now uh we also want to understand that
what are like what different this this
slide itself it has a huge number of
information but at the same time it also
tell us about the pathway like uh what
cellular omics can give us what
microbiome and virum uh information can
give us and what clinical and phenotypic
data can give us and when we combine all
of this what is a system biology
approach and how then we how we can then
discuss about the strategy the strategy
is to find a solution and the solution
comes from chemistry so how do we use
those drugs those may be biologics or
based on the data that we are getting so
this various types of omics data that is
described in detail
intercellular and intracellular
processes which are really associated
with common diseases and these data sets
can be analyzed to understand biology
behind host factors and as well as like
a micro biome composition in our bodies
and the environment we live in so
to drive infections and to cause you
know deterioration of health these also
have an effect on destabilizing the
immune system and let's these all of
this let led to you know clinical
manifestation of our disease
so um
it would be nice to to understand this
from a perspective of you know an
example for of uh so let's try out an
example so the way uh in which bacteria
infects infect
cells are important for understanding
the host pathogen interaction
agreed
so if it is true then the knowledge also
opens up a world of practical
applications so what are the
applications
so for example it can support the design
of
new anti
antibiotics or vaccines in
in case of
when we are discussing about healthcare
these are the different applications
when we are discussing about the soil or
marine bacteria it can help in creating
strategies for rebalancing natural
ecosystems so there is a huge
application
so one can use machine learning to
explore how bacteria interacts with the
environment by analyzing those so there
is this case study and this is a
recently published uh
article uh in nature
that shows that analyzing data from
uniprot database in itself and using uh
the
protein prediction software that
recently came out alpha fold uh
one can bridge uh like fill this gap and
knowledge in this area so there is this
study where uh fibrillar edison's these
are the proteins that are located on
bacterial cell surface and which mediate
interactions with the environment for
example host cells or the bacteria or
the other bacteria so there was a study
on this so these proteins are usually
have a stock
which helps them cross the bacterial
cell surface and be projected closer to
their targets so regardless of what they
are trying to bind to they will be they
will be this is the mechanism through
which they work so uh
the study uh analyzed the data from a
couple of species and then uh the
researchers were able to identify
more than 6500 of such
fibrillar addison's that were not seen
before and this was done through the
sequence analysis so uniprot is a
sequence database and uh i think many of
you know about uniprot very well and
then you uh we will be discussing in
this session also alpha fold and deep
minds uh this innovation which helped in
predicting the uh structure of those
fibrillar edisons and then we got to
know about
from this analysis
a new world perhaps
that is helping in the process of
binding which is so essential for
bacteria so this this work actually goes
beyond simple curiosity because by
understanding how bacteria interacts
with biotin or biotin surfaces
researchers can start to explore how
drug can be used to target these
interactions or whether the bacteria
living in our body or our environment
can be changed so this approach can uh
could allow researchers to improve the
health of gut microbiomes the bacterial
community living in a patient's gut for
example
so these are some of the uh
approaches that have been taken up by
the new multi-omics uh way of seeing
things and then integrating it with
the system biology approach and then the
computational uh
solutions so in this program and we've
been discussing this
that
uh how the different elements are you
know put together so uh
so when we are discussing about finding
new targets and when we are discussing
about
the data analysis part of
bioinformatics so you have heard about
transcriptomics and like how gene
expression patterns
in association with clinical data
help identify molecular biomarkers which
are used for diagnostics and for therapy
selection so new discoveries include a
better understanding of these complex
diseases at the subcellular level as
well as for target identification uh for
noble drug discovery and even for drug
repurposing so all of this is helpful
for us
to
towards
target discovery which is a very
important step in biomedical drug
discovery
now uh new target discovery so target
based screens as many of you are from
maybe biological background and know
about the target base based screens
so in wet lab or in when we are doing
experiments so target-based screens
offer a reductionist approach to drug
discovery because generally it's
employed
in in vitro biochemical assets to search
through the libraries of small molecules
so they are based on developing acids to
detect compounds that interact with the
specific molecular entity most often a
protein right which is known or
hypothesized from a basic research to be
involved in processes impaired in
disease of interest that's the drug
discovery concept that many of us think
it to be
so in that process phenotypic screening
in contrast employs a holistic approach
most often at the level of the cell
sometimes you get that data also from
cell from tissue or from organ or even
whole animals can be employed in some of
those studies so one of such example is
that uh the personalized medicine
example
is uh trust
uh trusts uh travis to zoom up class to
use the map which was a first in class
immunotherapeutic target
targeting the her2 tyrosine
kinases receptor and it's used to treat
patients with how to over express breast
tumors and we have a project on those
which project on this on learn portal
and also we cover it in a
transcriptomics program and but it is
important that how all of this is
connected so there is a molecular
approach that uses all of these
technologies i was discussing about and
gave give example for
gene expression studies uh where we
discussed about a biomarker and then the
the over expressing
how to breast tumors
and then there are genetic studies or
genomic studies where we are looking at
the panels where we are looking at the
mutations the variants so these are some
approaches then there is a system
approach that i've discussed then we
have all the different uh validations
that we can do utilizing bioinformatics
so this was a kind of an overview
to what we are doing why we are doing
this and how all of this is connected
because on the portal you will be able
to find uh different omics technologies
and then why we are doing chem
information so this is one of the major
component of this entire drug discovery
process so i hope that all of this
overview is kind of uh make sense and
it's clear to uh to you uh if if you
have any questions i'll be happy to
um happy to answer so um next part of
this program of this
presentation will include that what we
are going to do in terms of the
curriculum how we are going to cover
different aspects of what we have been
discussing and how all of this makes
sense
if you think about a research proposal
or a research project that you might be
thinking about or you are interested in
the future to work on
so today
we are meeting here and we are
discussing about uh the upcoming uh fall
program
which is scheme informatics for
biomedical drug discovery so this
program is going to start on 23rd august
and will run till
october
and
there are
models where you can join and complete
the program in either 45 days or 60 days
or 90 days based on the
uh maybe you are interested to work
further with us or work on a research
proposal all of this is possible within
a larger time frame and uh
in this program we will be recovering uh
through sessions and uh there will be
resources so i in this slide i wanted to
uh
simplify to all of uh all of you who are
who are
here today that
how this is
conceptualized and how the curriculum
works and what are the different
components that one will be having
access to to able to be able to get some
of the outcomes that we've been
discussing uh for this so we've been
discussing about the different types of
data different types of approaches and
how structural biology approach is an
important uh
critical component of this but uh you
have like all the coursework associated
with the other omics technologies that
would be integrated into this process
but if you want to work on structure
biology chem informatics and you already
have a defined idea
or a research target or sorry target
or a target in your mind then i think we
you can start from the
from the
uh
from the coursework that we are going to
offer as a part of this program which is
uh structural biology and chem
information coursework which kind of is
uh developed for beginners and this is
especially to those
who are either from high school or from
undergraduate level and would want to
start with a very basic understanding so
all of this omics logic training
involves a basic coursework then an
intermediate coursework and then the
research work so
for those who wants to get like an
understanding of uh how the basics work
we will be sharing the uh resources with
you these are the courses uh lessons
that will be support that will be
provided with every session uh
throughout the training program so that
everyone who is from a different
educational background or are from
non-biology background could also
work on this
so uh as i was saying that uh from uh
very basics to understanding of why we
are doing this where we can find
information and what kind of data is
there
so
these all questions are also being and
being answered so uh how protein acts
what is the future of structural biology
how animal spectroscopy works what is uh
what is uh cryo em and what are the
difference between like the when you
when you compare structures when you're
thinking about you know conducting a
experiment
and
experiment on structural biology drug
discovery drug designing what are the
things that you need to see so there are
some of the very basic important facts
when you are obtaining data when you are
obtaining structural data what are the
parameters you can you know uh check to
understand if the model that you're
considering is is of
is going to give you the right answers
or not so those basic concepts are being
uh discussed in these lessons and we are
adding more lessons in this uh in this
series as well
which will be which we will be sharing
with the participants of the program uh
throughout the training
now about the structure so it's it's
it's quite simple and uh it's uh it's
kind of flows from one session to
another and that's what i wanted to
cover in uh today's presentation mainly
that uh what what will be done
throughout the program so we will start
with the basic sessions where we
discussed about the um the uh the
structure what are the different types
of protein structures what are the
interactions where do you find this
computational resources for protein
protein interaction conformational
analysis protein folding
some of the basic concepts how this
happened and what are the computational
resources associated with some of the
prediction tools or some of the analysis
tools not prediction here because we are
doing a prediction uh different session
uh dedicated to predations but here we
are
going to discuss more about uh how to
you know find the tertiary structure the
secondary structure and build from there
then we are going to introduce first we
are going to discuss about big molecules
macromolecules and then we are going to
discuss about small molecules in the
same
prospect
that how to obtain and understand about
small molecules where do you find such
data what are the different ways to
understand this data what are different
ways to express this data in the
databases how to find this on all of
that so these are basic overview
sessions and then from here we go to the
actual databases and we start exploring
those databases because it's very
important to understand what is
available on public repositories
because you want to maximize and utilize
the public data and if you have
propriety data that is an added
thing that you can do in a research
project but in the terms of education
and learning we will be using the public
repositories and where
you will see that people are publishing
uh
almost thousands of articles
based on the analysis that are available
through the public repository and public
data so here uh there is an aspect of uh
hands-on activity which would involve um
use of some proper some free softwares
which uh where for which we will be able
to we will be able to share with you how
to install them and then show you how to
work on them so also we will be sharing
uh emails throughout this training
program so uh the emails will contain
information about the coursework but not
only the coursework but also
publications and link to all of the uh
all of the databases that we are
covering and the
and the certain uh repositories that we
are going to use
so all of this is like building up to
the uh knowledge of how to
first of all understand about the data
and information and then where to find
it and then how to download it and
visualize it and uh in this process we
will be using a lot of case studies from
rc us rcsb pdp and we will be using
protein data bank
by to compare structures and to
understand that what we what are the
experimental structures that are
available for our problem if there are
no experimental structures what would be
the strategy to model such uh such cases
in such cases and then like how do you
connect from uh different uh protein
like different complex interactions
because uh now with a lot of single
structures the world is now moving
towards the complex uh complexes
structure of complexes where more than
one proteins are involved in in certain
biological function which is greatly
[Music]
are associated with diseases and
mutations and all so we will be
discussing some case studies and then we
will be working on such uh such data
using the rcsb pdb protein data bank
where all the experimental structures
are available
so integrating this information
you can also
work on your own uh
project here so one of the idea is to
use
the structures that are available and we
will be able to do some search uh
searches based on the queries so here i
was as i was asking uh earlier
to share the project form so the project
form will involve uh that will include
the description about the protein of
interest and if there is literature
available on it so that we can start
working or start developing a proposal
now uh after doing that like when we
understand that where the structures are
how they how they are uh available and
what are the ways to visualize it
and uh what uh how how can we compare
and align and see the statistics so one
of the important aspect of you know
comparing and writing a publication or
writing a report or showing uh this to
the community requires some statistical
validation through tools and through
different analysis so that statistical
validation is something that we are
going to cover in that which involves
root mean squared deviation when we
compare structures in angstrom uh
unit and all of that and then we are
going to move to the session next
session which is more on target
structure prediction
where we are going to use uh the
structure prediction tools so this is a
critical part of drug discovery okay m
informatics based drug discovery for
preparing the receptor because uh
i mean one of the objective what you're
trying to do is you're trying to mimic
uh the
uh mimic what is happening within a cell
or within uh
within a uh system so
you want to make it as close as to the
actual uh actual um environment that in
which the structure is so there are
certain tools that we are going to use
we are going to understand from a plus
point of view of structural biologist if
the structure is making sense and if the
structure is properly modeled and to do
that we
want to validate one of the ways to use
multiple uh
multiple algorithms so we are going to
go get some hands-on activity on that so
the session is sort of divided in this
way so target identification processes
then what are the what are the actual
meanings as i was
describing you about target
identification and it goes in like
really really depth then we have protein
structure prediction why and how then
comparative protein modeling and alpha
fold and then there is a working session
so uh comparative protein modeling we
are discussing about a template based
modeling so template recognition how can
we find templates and find the right
kind of template because sometimes we
are trying like in in drug discovery
there are open there are different
confirmations for protein right and then
there are different ligand bound states
and when you look at the structural data
you'll find a lot of variations there
how to understand that and use that in
your experiment is very important so
that alignment back and then when we are
looking at the structure when we are
looking at a model then we are looking
at different components of the secondary
structure that has been modeled uh which
involves the loops that play a critical
role in many of the binding processes
whether it is maybe a small iron or a
metal line or or
or a ligand so loop modeling side chain
modeling model optimization model
validation some of these aspects that we
are going to discuss
and then uh use some of these modeling
tools which are very famous and used
utilized by uh
by the entire scientific community who
are working on the similar area such as
modeler or alpha fold so we will start
our alpha fold predictions from here and
understand what are the challenges
limitations and uh how can
this uh the predictions uh make sense in
biological context and if not what are
the solution strategies for that
so after target prediction uh the the
thing that one would want to learn about
is that yeah right i have now a good
system good biological system to test on
i have prepared a good target and
it mimics
what what is happening
it mimics almost of what is happening
within so we would want to now
understand that what are the solution
strategies so here onwards we are
discussing about the solution strategies
the virtual screening is one of such
strategy that is that is going to be
utilized and understood in this session
which is the session five which is where
we are almost at the midway so uh like
uh virtual screening can also be
optimized because the the
databases have millions and billions of
compounds small compounds and you don't
want to you can't actually
use all those all of those
molecules to screen at on on a single
protein or
multiple targets or whatever because
it's going to take forever and then also
it's computationally expensive and
extensive and expensive so you would
want to do a lot of optimization a lot
of you know knowledge based uh
screening so that's what we are going to
discuss in target identification and
then we have some case studies uh which
we have worked with uh in our in um in
our research projects with uh with
our collaborators one of such project is
roosevelt park cancer research institute
where we worked and
one of the molecule is
uh is being utilized for
treatment
and is effective so how does this
process happen
what are the different ways we did the
screening we utilized the topper
research platform and then
based on machine learning and
representation and clustering we kind of
reduced
the chemical space to a significant
space where you can actually now test
test them low so you would want to
reduce the chemical space from thousands
and millions of compounds to maybe 100
or 500 or 1000 and then you do more
intensive testing
virtually before finalizing top 10 or
top 100 for your experiments
now
then as i was saying that after virtual
screening it comes to very
specialized kind of screening which is
the
part where we discuss about molecular
docking
and it's a very popular pro
method and many of you might have been
aware of it and might have used it
already
but in this in the session we uh dr
puneet uh who has already prepared a lot
of sessions for you who will be
participating in the program which are
pre-recorded sessions uh for specific
tutorials that we have for this for this
uh session six which is practical
experience in docking where we will be
covering like tools such as argus lab a
highly featured molecular modeling and
graphics program
which works on windows and the program
contains two docking engines with a
small
with a scoring function which is very
much used which kind of gives you an
estimate of binding affinity
so maybe k a combining association or
something you can correlate it with uh
in
for the validation like uh if you're
comparing number of molecules which
would be the you know top 10 or how do
you filter them so
these are the tools that are used and
useful to filter them based on their
based on their binding and interactions
with even your protein molecule so this
is what we have planned uh and then we
have an interesting session which is uh
again now from from structure now we are
using more and more
about
how we can do this at a scalable
way by applying uh
statistical uh tools such as art
language or are our
coding so this is quite simple because
all of this is done in google collab
notebook which we will be sharing with
you and it has all the tutorials and you
can play the notebook and take up
and do the different steps and this is
you know why this is we are doing this
this is like you did the virtual
screening where you identified from a
large library of molecules into
and get leads
so after getting leads you you got maybe
top 10 or top 20 leads and you you are
looking at the
top poses and you're analyzing and
you're checking the interaction but can
you optimize it further so for
optimization what you need is something
that are
that medicinal chemist are expert in
that chemist are working working in that
changing the different orientation
changing functional groups and doing
more drug optimization so this session
actually helps in those who are into
drug optimization so chem informatics
and using r
and those google column notebooks you
can generate different confirmations and
change it by uh by just changing few
sentences or the group information in
the in the notebook so all of this is
quite uh automated and it's really easy
to use and that's one of the objective
for creating such a curriculum so that
it's easy to use and implement and later
once you
gain expertise and more and more
expertise you'll be more easy and
comfortable to go for advanced uh
research
so uh after this we have an uh
discussion on a case study so this is a
case study based uh um session uh
by one of the experts from an industry
to discuss about the drug discovery
process the high throughput process the
structural biology screening and some of
the case studies which is to discovery
of a kinase inhibitor for lung cancer so
we will have a pharma expert
from from the industry discussing about
this
after that we we are in during this
process
are going to discuss or share with you a
lot of publications that would make
sense for you to develop research ideas
and encourage you to develop research
ideas if you don't have already one
so in this uh towards the ninth session
and we are towards the
last three sessions of the program we
are going to discuss advancements in uh
ai based molecular drug discovery so in
in this session we are going to deep
dive in more in um into the alpha fold
predictions so alpha fold uh you know in
a way uh
they have already predicted 200 million
structures uh
this is the news that i've heard like
couple of weeks ago uh so all the unifor
uniprot protein sequences are now
modeled so you can
simply utilize those and then based on
uh
all of that there are some limitations
still there that uh you know that alpha
fold is not able to solve so what are
those limitations for example the
structures for which there is no
information at all like noble structures
obviously alpha fold can't solve the
struct uh give you solution for that
because it does not have the training or
the training on such data so what are
the solution strategies and what are the
different
case studies in terms of how pharma and
computational biology companies are
utilizing this uh
ai in molecular drug discovery how
academy and industry is utilizing this
ai in drug discovery and how we can
as a researcher or as a scientist or as
a student uh can uh incorporate or
get some of this technology in and use
it for our own research uh many of them
open source or if we can develop
something using the resources that and
with our mentors
so um as i was telling you about uh the
ai introduction so uh as alpha fold i
was telling you that they have now open
it open it for open access this open
access
open access database is available for
all of us and we will be downloading and
we will be looking at that so some of
the limitations that i was telling you
in the previous and to the previous
slides are listed about here actually so
different versions of alpha fold and
then there are uh
in biology you will find uh
some proteins are functional as uh as
multi alzheimer's so how do we do
complexes so i was telling you that this
is a challenge and uh this is something
that uh people are trying to solve
especially structural biologists who are
working on specific problems especially
working with research groups who have a
biological background and they are
conducting experiments and knowing from
the
from the illusion that what is the
what is the weight and based on the
molecular weight uh how many um how if
it is a multimeric protein or there are
different ways to know that so from that
information can we can can we produce
those models so again to the same point
that i've been discussing for a while
the correctness of the model is pretty
important and it should include all the
biological information and insights that
we know of so the more we can build that
uh closer to the biological information
the more the chances are for us to get
the right kind of result so alpha fold
on that and then mutations there's a
huge huge challenge with mutations so
i've been working on many projects which
involves mutation obviously with covert
and all the
cancer mutations so how do you
understand what are the structural
changes how how do you capture the
structural changes because what you are
seeing is just a snapshot is not the
complete picture so here the you know uh
application of molecular dynamic
simulations and uh normal mode analysis
and then different types of
wholesale simulations comes into picture
and that would be maybe a research topic
or as a research that one can do
so as we've been discussing about uh the
same thing
so in the context the case study that we
will be discussing in this uh will be a
pharma company who is utilizing
the information
and the
deep learning processes for not only
screening and all of that but for new
molecular
new molecule generation using graph
theory and using deep learning so how
they are utilizing this and uh what are
the different uh solutions that they
have come up with because uh many of
these are we thought many of these are
experimental but what are the different
uh situation in the market if it is it
is
it is going to be successful or not if
it is what stage it is in so those are
the different uh those are the though
that's the case study that we have that
we are going to discuss
and then we have uh the session on uh
data warrior which will be discussed
towards the end of the program
where which is to you know understand
all of this so we i just discussed that
calculation of key chemical properties
generation of new chemical compounds and
identification of chemical
representation so before that we
discussed about the case study so that
you know that what is the application
and then you have you are excited to
learn this yourself
so uh that it would be what we are going
to cover in the advanced game
informatics session uh which is the last
i think one of the last sessions and
then we have some of the case studies uh
which is very important so uh at the
beginning of all of this we will be
start we will be we'll be working on um
we will be working on the project form
so if many any of you have a project
idea and you want to work on a project
next session we are going to discuss
about the research projects so what are
the cam informatics research projects
how to design a chem information
research projects what is the different
stages challenges and limitation and
then the omics logic research fellowship
so this is towards the end so anyone who
has been working on a project or would
want to develop a project and work on
that can work with me we can work with
dr raghav can work with the industry
experts dr kunit uh which would be
through the homicide research fellowship
so this is the 11th uh session uh more
about uh what are the next steps that
one can take so we have several of these
case studies integration of omics data
into research projects pharma pro
projects for bioma biomolecular or
biomarker discovery so these all come
boils down to the structure of the
protein and understanding so these have
the chem informatics component and then
the kobe 19 case study
where we are discussing understanding
the different binding
domains and then strategizing based on
the structure and what are the different
uh
ways to look at infectious disease
research so one of the things that we
have been discussing is about all of
this in the respect of
protein structure so protein structure
as it's a
organic
molecule with a lot of
chemicals uh
forming the structure and there is also
a component of electrostatic uh
distribution the charge distribution the
hydrophobicity what are the different um
phys
physiologic or physical properties of
the amino acid and how does that make a
difference when it comes down to you
know
binding so this is all knowledge based
and this can be gained through this
simple structural analysis by utilizing
some of the tools that the structural
biologists or computational structural
biologists utilized and i will be able
to share some of my knowledge and
information that i've gained and worked
on
and
on the publications that i've been able
to publish so far so i'll be able to
help in that and then we have the last
session which is more about uh
the
uh about the case study that what are
the examples of successful and failed
drug discovery development by one of the
industry experts uh to know and
understand that what are the
different things that we have to look
into when we are discussing about drug
discovery and what people have done and
what they have learned so far from this
experience so that's uh that's the
entire structure of this uh program and
i hope that many of you would be
interested in doing so
throughout the training program and we
have like working sessions and i have a
small small
exercise today that uh maybe we can try
so
[Music]
will that be fine for you
okay thank you percy you you
i got your
yes
so all right
all right so um before we do this i just
wanted to share with you the project
proposal uh form
and
the project proposal form uh is
something that we are going to share
with the program participant and uh what
it was what it helps is that it's from
the very beginning uh it it gives you
the opportunity to start working
learning about these different
technologies and tools and
case studies and maybe apply it for your
own project so you have to share the
project title project description
summary
some lines and thoughts about what you
have uh what project idea that you would
want to work on link to some raw data
means the protein data bank or some
reference publications and from here we
build it into a proposal and then into a
research project so that's the project
proposal form
and now uh back to the uh back to
our
our
exercise
so can you all uh so let me share this
in the chat
that would be helpful
the sequence
of
the protein
so let's identify if you have a protein
sequence how do you identify what
protein it is that's the first question
second question is to find uh this uh
this uh
protein
using this protein identifier
uh find this into in the pdb
and find the uniprot id and then try to
predict the structure so these are the
three different exercises
that actually
i think one of the issue is that we are
running out of time and
we have reached towards the end of the
session so we can do one thing that we
will be able to share with you
the um the exercise and also um in
couple of days the
uh the solution and uh in the meantime
it'll be great if you start uh
start uh joining the program and then
we'll be able to share with you the more
resources
and uh to tell you more about that uh
i'll pass it pass the stage to sunalika
share you can please put it in the chat
box and uh some will be able to answer
your question
and now i would like to take this
session i had to explain how you can
register for this program
uh so i'll just share the link to the
program page the chat box first of all
so the session scheduled that doctor
mohit went through uh extensively is
mentioned here on the program page you
can find the schedule here with all the
topics that would be covered along with
the sessions title and also the
associated resources
uh these resources and also the links to
the tools and databases will be given
along with the uh supplemental material
of the program itself all right and now
if you want to register yourself for the
program
all you have to do is just visit the
program page and
scroll down to reach to the registers
section
here you can see three different
subscription levels which includes an
access to the program for 45 days 60
days or 90 days
now to make sure some of the points i
wanted to clarify here that the access
to the session recordings and the
supplementary material would be the same
for all of these three subscription
level types the difference lies only in
the access to
the
portal for the duration of access to the
resources and also to the research
project so in the 45 days of the
subscription level you'll be able to
go through the resources that includes
the record the pre-recorded
sessions as put on the program page
associated resources and if you want
one-on-one mentor guidance for the
questions that you come across uh taking
access
to those 660 days of the program would
be perfect for you where you can
schedule one-on-one meetings based on uh
your availability with the mentor and
take your questions
and if you want to work on a research
project then in doing the 90 days
program would be the perfect option for
you
so in the 60 days option you'll be able
to complete the program and also come up
with the research proposal so you can
meet the mentor and discuss your
research ideas after a literature review
and then come up with a research
proposal design your hypothesis and if
you want to work on a research project
and get a certificate and get a
publication out of it then the 90-day
subscription would be the best that you
can pick
now uh if you belong to uh
a different country so this is mentioned
in dollars
and if you belong to let's say india or
some other country here you can
simply pick the option by clicking on
this country option that comes on the
top right in the menu bar i just click
on inr you need to click over here and
the currency would be changed here for
the registration type this would be easy
for you now to proceed ahead with
so that is the simplest way how you can
do this to yourself or the program
and if there are any questions about
registration you can ask us the team is
here also we have here uh miss kashthar
she will help you get started with the
program she'll help you in your
registration process
um
yes definitely there are we have the
scholarship option available for the
program as well and uh spanish can share
the scholarship form with you there are
can you please put your email address
okay thank you sparsh uh she has put her
email address here there are you can
reach out to spurs on marketing
solid.com and she'll help you out with a
scholarship form you need to fill out
the scholarship form your application
will be reviewed by uh us and then we'll
get back to you with the possibilities
on what scholarship can you get to enjoy
for the program
thank you
now if you have any other questions
please let us know in the chat maybe you
can also mute yourself and
we would be glad to help you out with it